I play Daphne Milne I am the wife of a a
Milne and the mother of Christopher
Robin
she's a very complicated woman
especially when you look at her through
modern eyes I didn't want to shy away
from any of her faults you know the one
good thing about the war is owned lots
of marvelous women around like you we're
never going to get married because there
are no men so you can take on work like
girls yes that's true
she could be quite cold spirited she had
no time for tears she's no time for
sentimentality all those worst things
she's never got anything just on the tip
of her tongue it's always just right out
there
what Margot is doing is not apologized
for anything she's just said no this is
who she is and this is how she deals
with things and she's found the joy in
that but we're going on holiday just to
Italy for a month or so they were the
parents at their time but it was quite
natural to give birth and head off to
Italy for six weeks leaving the baby
with a nanny it's a different time and
it makes it so interesting to watch this
family dynamic ting just look perfect
Daphne's definitely wanted to have a
girl I think that made it difficult for
her to connect with Christopher Robin
and yet you know you can see the joy in
Daphne's face when she gives the boy the
toy was clear she loved him very very
much in her own way yes very glad
friends there be no trouble do you have
any objections
Tigers no I didn't one of the reasons I
wanted to do this project was because my
mom used to do voices for my wienie the
Pooh and my Teddy's which is what Daphne
does too Christopher Robin in this film
Margot and she was doing all the accents
for the toys I found a quite funny as
well and it was really nice you do know
it was me talking not the bad Alice is
playing you you see how instrumental she
was to the creation of Winnie the Pooh
the whole way through you see that she's
the driving force to creating this the
evening news which will be on the front
page without realizing it it was putting
a huge strain on her family but she had
the best intentions he's going to
little forever back my boy
you
[Music]
god bless mommy god bless daddy god
bless you amen forgotten someone who
keep thinking me I forgot to bless me
God bless me a tooth to meaningless
funniest writer ready to put the smile
back on our faces
let me fight that war but it is over
what am i doing about it you're doing
what you're good at writing place I had
enough of making people laugh I want to
make them see I need to get out of
London somewhere quiet and trying to
think for once you're going to live here
this is your new home mommy says you're
writing a book stop people going toward
me I think the book is a journey did I
get you're the only one that does it
really like if you wrote a book for me I
definitely read it shall we go for a
walk aren't you working it doesn't seem
likely do you think of a good name for a
donkey your
they'll be gone in a minute piece of
your job they they just work to make
honey yes I completely forgot about bees
[Music]
creepiest find something to be happy
about I think I've got something for us
Ernest and I are putting your bear in a
book or putting you in it too what do
you call me in the book your real name
Christopher Robin
that's the hunters in the snow creatures
in the story and toys their toys but the
woods are real we neither Pooh it's
rather inexplicable yes
Evening News Christopher on the front
page
why does everyone like Winnie the Pooh
sandwich after the war there was so much
sadness then we need the booty Malone
shall we go to the work I've got heaps
of writing to do I'm afraid he has to be
allowed to grow up he has to know he's
important
radio into the newspaper interview he
can't do all this was father goat is it
he's a little boy boy
[Music]
come on man where to home I should think
[Music]
you